ten years ago, a passageway called a
gate suddenly appeared that connected us to another dimension, and
events that exceeded common sense began to occur all over the world.Those who
awakened to the ability to fight are
called hunters.Thank
you again for today.  Please, that brother is
also known as humanity's weakest weapon. I
don't think he's stubbornly continuing to be a hunter. It's okay, please. He's just too
weak. He's
going to work within the family.
Look at that big stone statue.  That's what
happened. I'm awake. I'll be killed. I'll
still
survive. I've definitely
tried my best to live my life.
If I had one more chance,
Shonji's hunter,
haven't you awakened after awakening?
Awakened after awakening, no way.  Is this something that only I can see? You should take better care of yourself. You
must have been really worried. I've got all my
equipment ready, I've done what I needed to do.
I'm the boss all by myself, no party, but I
have no choice but to do it.
[Music] Hey,
what should I do?  It's because I'm
weak that I'm being suspected like that. I'm
being criticized because I'm weak. Let's
fight passionately.
If we can become stronger, we'll follow these stupid rules.
[Music]